hello wonderful folks of wonderful I
hope you're enjoying my review of
Captain America's Civil War or my
spoiler talk to Captain America Civil
War funny thing I'm editing my spoiler
talk because everyone was like spoiler
talks boys are talking as I'm editing it
it ground to a halt people like whoa you
guys talk about the Power Rangers suits
dude surprisingly large amount of people
and I was a big Power Rangers fan from
back in the day so I saw it and I was
like all right let's talk about that I
do have some thoughts among a lot of the
internet rage that's happening because
they're ultimately Robo suits first of
all let's backtrack a bit I didn't even
touch on the Rita thing because I saw
picture Rita I'm like let's see how the
Power Rangers look now the battery just
came out I'm like alright let's talk
about that thing because Reena kind of
looks like [ __ ] let's be honest she
looks like poison ivy had sex with
Witchblade in the 90s directed by Joel
Schumacher I have to cap that off with
Joel Schumacher because poison ivy
having sex with Witchblade sounds
awesome but seriously she looks more
like Scarpino than Rita maybe that's in
the plot maybe score Pina overthrew Rita
and now she's running Rita's thing it's
gonna play into the plot maybe probably
not just probably just Rita but now for
the Rangers alright you look at the Robo
suits visually speaking I really don't
have a problem with it I actually look
pretty cool before you start blowing
that comment section up here's why
because first of all they kept the
colors to it I've seen designs of power
industries there been some fan films of
Power Rangers not dissing any fan films
I think it's really cool when people do
fan films you guys should keep it up I'm
just saying this is a critique I saw
when the costume designs for the Power
Rangers suits came out it was a lot of
black and the trim was more or less the
colour of the Power Rangers people were
like dude it's a lot of black with a
little bit of Truman color but it's kind
of boring so it looks like the director
and the costume designers for this movie
got together than like alright whatever
we do keep the color fans want the
colors fans hate it when you lose the
color and fans hate it when you lose the
spandex I guess and they can do some
really cool stuff with the Chesapeake I
notice a little like Iron Man chest
pieces that they have and so they could
do some sort of holographic like depth
image word what am I trying to say it
looked like the logo for the dinosaur
will be inside the suit it could look
really cool I'm just saying or they
could be just boring a little triangles
on their chests that have no real
function or purpose and that would be
stupid
people don't like something like this
it's ultimately it has to do with their
nostalgia and now they thought this
movie was going to serve their nostalgia
and now what they're afraid of because
the visual
presentation maybe people were like
arena sucks but we'll see how the
Rangers are alright well that sucks and
now the suck and the suck exponentially
compound on the suck and as them it just
all sucks so when I see Robo suits I
have a couple of fears one they're not
going to be very mobile I feel like all
the martial arts coolness that makes
Power Rangers Power Rangers and made
Mighty Morphin Power Rangers that Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers that I knew when I
was a kid it's not gonna be there how
much can you actually move in a suit
like that this all matters because in
the end if they are doing martial arts
are we going to hear the suits make
sounds I think it'd make like robot
sounds when they're doing hurricane
kicks like new don't do that no it is a
tough thing to do alright spandex do we
go with spandex we did that before when
it was cheesy [ __ ] nostalgic yeah we
love it yeah it's cheesy as [ __ ] do we
do that weird material that sit up mats
and gyms are made out of that they did
in the Power Rangers movie from the 90s
oh that looks cheesy too now that looks
like 90s cheese so I really don't know
what the alternative would be other than
to make them look metal in metallic and
robot because robots are cool in this
movie is ultimately nostalgia side made
for kids but the MMPR fan film that came
out a while back is like Power Rangers
for adults they didn't use any metal
then it actually was pretty sweet
Randy the Power Ranger suits weren't on
screen very long maybe if they were on
screen longer we would had gripes about
it I don't know probably not though cuz
that [ __ ] was really cool so when their
attempt to get away from 90s cheese they
went full 80s animation seriously does
it not look like a rainbow beam just hit
this Silverhawks fournier's I've said it
before I'll say it again picture is
worth a thousand words and a trailer is
worth a thousand pictures I need to see
this in action I need to see how they do
it so all our fears can either be
justified we're like nope that actually
does suck as much as we may have thought
it did or oh no actually it's pretty
sweet it's pretty cool they're doing a
lot with it
I like it now my main concern I'm just
lay is the Megazord Megazord that it'll
be difficult I want to see the dinosaurs
be apart I want to see a dinosaur arm
and another dinosaur body for another I
want it to look like Power Rangers I
don't want it to be like transformers
where it all just shuffles and now it's
a big robot that you can't even tell
what it is alright that's my rant on
that you guys asked for it those are my
thoughts on the Power Rangers suits I
see potential and I can see why people
are afraid of it right guys so the
Mighty Morphin Power Rangers movie suits
have you seen them what need
about them and Rita what did you think
about her whatever you think about all
of this I meant below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more